نتابع بشان السوداني وينضم الينا من
نيروبي الفريد متاوى وزير الخارجيه الكيني
اهلا بك سيد الفريد سيد الفريد تقييمكم
للوضع في السودان بعد ثلاثه اسابيع من
المواجهات
تقييمنا انه لم يتغير شيء كثير منذ ان
بدات هذه الحرب والامور زادت سوءا كانت
نتيجه
للقتال المستمر والذي لم يفاجئنا نحن في
افريقيا فحسب بل العالم اجمع انه امر مؤسف
ان كلا الجنرلين قرر ان يقاتل بعضهما
البعض على حسابي شعبي السودان
سيد الفريد لم تكونوا تتوقعون هذه
المواجهات بين الجانبين
نعم تفاجانا كما قلت لانه كانت هناك
مفاوضات وعمليه سياسيه وكانت الايجاد
والاتحاد الافريقي وفعلين اخرين في العالم
حيث وصلنا الى اتفاق ينتظر فقط التوقيع
عليه ما عدا جزئيه صغيره تتعلق بالكيفيه
التي سيتم بها دمج القوات الحكوميه
والقوات والميلات المسلحه وتوقعنا ان يتم
حل تلك الاشكاليه في غضون ايام والكل تصور
اننا انتهينا من كل شيء لنصح ذات صباح
ونرى ان القتال اندلع في الخرطوبه هذه
مفاجاه وكل ما ممكن نفكر به هو ان هناك
اناس لا يريدون عمليه السلام ولا يريدون
الانتقال من الحكم العسكري الى الحكم
المدني اذا هذا القتال تم نتيجه
لمبادره للحفاظ على الوضع الراهن سيد من
تقصدون باناس لا يريدون الانتقال الى
الحكم المدني والانتهاء من الحكم العسكري
من هم هؤلاء
نحن نشعر ان هناك
هم يرون ان
الاستمرار في القتال وهم ومنذ فتره طويله
ليسوا راغبين في استطباب الحكم المدني وهم
يقاومون التغيير انا لا اريد ان اسمي
الاسماء هم يعرفون انفسهم والعالم يعرفهم
وهذا الامر لم يكن
عرضيا وهم طبعا هم لا يريد لم يريدون لم
يريدوا ان يذهبوا الحرب بانفسهم فقط بل
ارادوا ان يجروا اخرين معهم وهم يصبون
الزيت على النار لكي يضمنوا ان تندلع هذه
المواجهات بل لا تتوقف بعد اندلاعها
الكيني يجرون اتصالات
ويحاولون ويسعون من اجل وقف المواجهات هذه
الجهود الى اين وصلت
المحاولات تحققت بدرجه معينه بقدر معين
اولا استطعنا التواصل مع الجنرال لا
نتوصلنا الى ابرامي هدنه واصبح الناس
قادرين على مغادره البلد وان يتم اجلائهم
وجنرالان يستمعان
ويستمعان الى مبادره الايجاد والى مطالبات
العالم بالسماح
للاغاثه الانسانيه ان تتدفق
ايضا على وقف اطلاق نار اذا هذا امر يعني
تقدما بسيطا لكننا ادركنا ايضا في ذات
الوقت ان الامر لا يتعلق بالجنرلين فقط
الامر يتعلق بالشعب السودان الامر لا
يتعلق بشخصين لديهما جيشان ولديهما جيش
وذخيرته لا تنثر لكن الطعام الشعب سينفذ
هؤلاء مستعدان للقتال حتى الامر لا يتعلق
بهما الامر يتعلق بشعب السودان البريء اذا
المبادره من قبل الرئيس من كينيا مبادرته
مبادره الاتحاد الافريقي تعني ان من يهم
في الامر كله هو الشعب السودان والامر كله
يتعلق بهم و بالوصول الى حكم مدني في
السودان سيد الفريد فيما تقول ان
الجنرالين يستمعان الى المبادرات والى
الايجاد وكيل وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه في
جولته يقول انه لا حاجه لمبادرات وساطه
تهدف لحل الازمه في السودان ويؤكد ان هذا
النزاع نزاع داخلي اذا اين يترك ذلك كل
هذه المبادرات
اعتقد ان امر الجميع يعرف انه محظو هراء
نحن نعيش في عالم مترابط العالم يبقى
متفرجا وهم يقتلون بعضهم البعض ويدمرون
مدينه جميله مثل الخرطوم الخرطوم تتدمر
البنى التحتيه القوه الانترنت انظمه
المياه والكهرباء كلها تتدمر وهو امر
احتاج الى الاف مئات السنين ربما والكثير
من المال لبنايه الخرطوم
واصبحت هذه المدينه العظيمه الان هي
متهالكه لا يمكن ان نقول ان العالم سيجلس
ويتفرج فقط اذا ما راينا الى ما يحدث في
اوكرانيا نرى ان العالم وقف على رجليه
وقال يجب ان نتدخل حول ما يحدث شكرا
انظروا الى جمهوريه الكونغو الديمقراطيه
اخرون من الخارج دخله من اجل الحلال
السلام في جمهوريه الكونغو الديمقراطيه
نعم قضيه اثيوبيا وجبهه
احتجنا الى مبادره السلام من قبل كينيا
ولاعبين اخرين وفاعل اخرى لكي نتواصل مع
طرفي النزاع لا يمكن ان نقول حل المشكله
بانفسنا انتم هم الذين تسببتم بالمشكله
وانتم الذين
وانتم تسببتم بوجود جثث قتلى تاكلها
الكلاب في شوارع الخرطوم وان ملايين الناس
يموتون بسبب عدم القدره على الحصول على
ادويه من بين سبعين مستشفى في الخرطوم فقط
10 منها يفعل يؤدي عمله اذا كنت تعاني من
عجز الكلى وتحتاج الى غسيل كلها وغيرها من
الخدمات من يعالج هؤلاء سيموتون انتم لا
تستطيعون
يقولون انكم ست حله هم يعتقدون انهم
سيحققون النصر فسيتقاتلون حتى الموت انا
اقول لكم رساله من العالم من السهوله
البدء بحرب لكن من الصعوبه جدا انهائها
وانتم تحتاجون الى اصدقائكم نحن في القاره
الافريقيه نؤمن بان اصوات البنادق يجب ان
تصمت وان الافارقه يجب ان يشاركوا في حل
مشكلاتهم ونحن لن نقف موقف المتفرج وكل من
الجنرلين يحاول انهاء الاخر في ظل رفض
الطرفين السماع او طرفان السماع لهذه
المبادرات هل تخشون من التداعيات لهذه
المواجهات على الاقليم
نحن قلقون بشان عدد من الامور عندما يتعلق
الامر بالسودان اولا نحن قلقون من تفكك
السودان لا نريد السودان ان يتفكك الى
جيوب صغيره
وتصبح الامه السودانيه امه بلا دوله ثانيا
نحن قلقون بسبب الازمه الانسانيه في
المنطقه ووفقا للمفوضيه اللاجئين السابع
والمتحده هناك اكثر من مليون من النازحين
داخل السودان قبل حتى بدا هذا النزاع
ولدينا الان مئات الالاف من السودانيين
يفرون عبر الحدود الى البلدان المجاوره
لدينا هناك ايضا
نازحين يضاف عددهم الى المليون الذين
كانوا موجودين اصلا نحن قلقون بسبب معاناه
الشعب السوداني الذي عانى لفتره طويله
ثالثا اينما كانت هناك
حكومات وبلدان في هذه القاره وفي اي قاره
اخرى لا تمتلك نظام حكم مستقر وتحدث
الحروب الاهليه تصبح هذه البلاد ارضا خصبه
للارهاب وللمشكلات ولمن ياتي من الخارج
ليسرق سنوات الشعب الرابعه نحن لا نريد
للسودان ان يصبح مسبحا وارضا لحرب
بالوكاله اما من قوى عظمى او قوى اخرى
تريد ان تحل مشكلاتها داخل السودان ومن
خلال دعم طرف ضد اخر شكرا لك سيده متوازير
الخارجيه الكينيه كنت معنا من نيروبيها